families pack everything they own and
head for safety forced from their homes
unsure where they're going or if they'll
ever return many have already fled other
parts of the country during Syria's
nine-year Civil War my daughter is about
to give birth and I don't know what is
going to happen to her
I don't know where we are going to live
where we are going to go this is what
they're running from Syria and Russia
are attacking rebel-held it lived from
the air on the ground fighting has
intensified with reports of heavy
battles between rebels and government
forces a renewed drive by President
Bashar al-assad to recapture the
country's last opposition Enclave in the
Northwest has sparked a new Exodus on
Monday tens of thousands of civilians
fled towards Turkey's border since
December it's estimated that more than
350,000 people have been displaced from
the region people can no longer handle
all this shelling many had been very
patient and waited but today they all
fled because of the regime's advancement
Syrian regime forces are edging closer
to maarat al-nouman it's now largely
deserted and destroyed after months of
bombardment but it sits on the m5
highway which links Damascus to Syria's
second city Aleppo the uk-based Syrian
Observatory for Human Rights says
government forces have reached the
city's eastern northern and southern
outskirts its capture would mark a
significant advance in al-assad's drive
to take back all of Syria
but as fighting escalates the human cost
is also rising organizations here are
totally powerless that's why we are
calling on the UN and other
international associations to intervene
turkey which backs some rebel groups
opposed to al-assad's regime already
hosts more than 3.5 million Syrian
refugees
this latest bombardment could
potentially lead to more soon crossing
the border Nicola gage al Jazeera